lots of recent free speech debates have
come up in colleges here are 10 rules
for how the freedom of speech applies to
college students 1 students of public
colleges may not be disciplined for
their speech unless it falls into the
narrow First Amendment exceptions such
as true threats of criminal attack or
face-to-face personal insults that are
likely to start a fight that's true even
if the speech is seen as evil or
offensive whether racist sexist
religiously bigoted unpatriotic
supportive of crime or whatever else for
instance a federal appeals court held
that public university students can't be
disciplined for putting on an ugly woman
skit at a fraternity event in which one
of the students was in blackface to a
public college can't limit broadly
available benefits based on a groups
viewpoint you can't for instance deny
bulletin board space to groups that
spread religious views
anti-homosexuality views racially
offensive parodies or any other views 3
this is also true for student-run
newspapers unless the college so
controls the newspaper that it's being
as being partly the university's own
speech for inside the classroom though
the professor is in charge professors
may orchestrate class discussions in a
way that they think brings out important
ideas and facts and promotes student
participation that means they can cut
off students who speak off topic or who
insult their classmates professors can
also ask students to make the best
argument for a particular viewpoint and
tell students that certain views say
that the earth is 6,000 years old are
wrong we expect professors to be
broad-minded on many issues and not
unduly blocked student opinions just
because they disagree with those
opinions but the First Amendment doesn't
give students a right to speak in the
classroom when the professor cuts them
off 5 grading of student exams and
papers likewise can't be content neutral
or even viewpoint neutral professors
shouldn't grade down students based on
mere ideological disagreement and
colleges may forbid outright political
discrimination by professors but grading
student work inevitably requires a
judgement about the quality of that work
and in many disciplines that will be a
subjective judgment based on more than
just objectively determinable facts 6
colleges and college departments can
express their own views or can foster a
selected set of views without giving
equal time to up
if a history department puts on a
conference for instance it can choose
the panelists based on their viewpoints
even if that means excluding some
viewpoints and preferring others seven
people have no First Amendment right to
shout down speakers whether the speaker
is the guest speaker in a class or
speaker invited by a student group most
speeches at colleges let listeners ask
questions including critical ones during
a Q&A at the end and there's usually
ample room to leaflet or protest on
sidewalks outside the building but it's
perfectly constitutional to have content
neutral rules banning interruptions when
a speaker has the floor and that give
invited speakers the opportunity to
speak without sharing that opportunities
with students or others indeed such
rules may be necessary to make such
speeches and debates possible eight a
public college has no First Amendment
obligation to protect speakers against
shouting down or even against violence
but it would violate the First Amendment
for the colors to selectively refuse to
protect speakers who express some views
while protecting others nine
content-neutral fees and restrictions
are likely constitutional but a public
college probably violates student groups
First Amendment rights when it charges
high security fees for invited speakers
who express controversial views 10 all
this of course applies only to public
colleges because the First Amendment
only applies to the federal state and
local governments not to private
organizations even private nonprofits
that get tax exemptions and government
subsidies but many colleges voluntarily
promise to uphold student free speech
rights as part of the college's
commitment to academic freedom and as a
way of attracting students and donors
and in California a state statute apply
some first amendment rules to private
colleges as well as public ones so to
sum up students at public colleges may
not be disciplined for their speech a
public college can't limit broadly
available benefits based on the group's
viewpoint that's also true for
student-run newspaper classroom the
professor is in charge grading of
student exams and papers can't be
content neutral or even viewpoint
neutral colleges and college departments
can express their own views without
giving equal time to others people have
no First Amendment right to shout down
speakers a public college can't
selectively protect some speakers but
not others based on viewpoint content
neutral fees and restrictions are likely
constitutional and these rules generally
only apply to public colleges but in
California some of them apply to private
colleges as well this is not legal
advice if this were legal advice it
would be followed by a bill please use
responsibly
written by Eugene Bullock who's an
actual real-life First Amendment law
professor at UCLA I'm Eugene Bullock and
I approve this message
[Music]